one of the best ways a police officer
can condition themselves to violence and
confrontation I currently train
jiu-jitsu but I'm not cute I am but I am
curious what else I can do to keep
myself and others safe from
unpredictable violence this is not a
self-defense question or either a mental
conditioning question very cool question
I appreciate that question because this
individual recognizes that there's a
little bit more to it than just the
physical self-defense and that's the
mental and he's 100% right so here's
some things that you can do when you get
the opportunity you got to get some
realistic training going and I've talked
about a little bit on here with a kind
of realistic training that we did in the
SEAL Teams there's things that up the
intensity greatly simunition or like a
paintball scenario another good thing is
getting a you know really heavy sparring
equipment on so face gear you know and
really go to town when you're trying to
attack someone and take them down
and do it you know three on one four on
one got to be careful not to get hurt
you don't want go that extreme but if
someone puts on head gear you know with
a face mask and the whole nine yards
shin guards and padded outfit on and
people can attack them and you have to
react to it the other good thing to do
is do it in a situation where you know
you don't let the guy know what's going
to happen you know he's got to keep his
eyes closed until you say go when he
opens his eyes there's someone there
with a knife right in front of feint
knife right in front of them is gonna
stab and he's got a draws weapon and
shoot or defend himself somehow so you
want to hit him with these unexpected
drills with your weapons without your
weapons shooting and moving so those are
those the kind of things as soon as you
get the opportunity to do it and it's
even good I mean if you've been in a in
a in a
Oh in a shooting drill with like a
barricaded shooter which is you know you
put a shooter at the end of the hallway
and he's hidden but he's shooting at you
with paintball and you get you can get
the intensity up very high it's the
getting shot with paintball hurts and if
you're getting nailed and you've got to
do something and people are like I gotta
make a call go do something you got to
make it happen how you gonna stop this
guy you can get your intensity up and
you can get used to that you can
inoculate yourself somewhat to that
stress and learn to detach yourself from
it and not let it affect you and not let
it grind on you so that's the realistic
training and and honestly I when I watch
some of the police videos of the bad
shootings now we know police officers
throughout the country every day are
under a burden of hostility and they do
an outstanding job over and over again
making great arrests and helping people
and saving people that are suicidal
incredible amount of things right of
course no one releases those videos and
they don't go viral the videos that go
viral and the videos that people watch
are the the bad ones
the bad ones and I hope that the police
departments across America are doing
something to inoculate their troopers
from the stress cuz that when I watch
these videos that is what I see
happening the the stress level and the
the inexperience of the stressful
situation and there's one video that I
watched which was awful and the guy gets
a call you see is you see his the first
thing you see oh no it the whole thing
is a body camera and forgive me if
someone pulls this video up and I'm not
100% accurate but he gets a call it's at
a 7-eleven guy with a gun guy pulls into
a 7-eleven the cop pulls into the
7-eleven as he gets out of his car and
he sees a guy kind of walk in one
direction out of the 7-eleven and turn
and walk
another direction guys got a hoodie on
he's walking away
so the cop gets out he's yelling at him
hey stop stop stop that guy doesn't stop
finally he's now approaching him and
he's standing in the open and this is
something that I see in a lot of these
videos these cops they stand in the open
when if you imagine that the other guy
has a gun why would you stand in the
open take cover
hmm you take cover that's the first
thing you do if you're even if you're
trying to stop somebody or trying to
yell at someone you take cover so if
they turn around to have a gun you only
have a small portion your body exposed
and you don't get scared because you're
hanging out in the open yeah
so so anyways this guy is approaching
he's standing out in the open he's
yelling at the guy finally the guy turns
around and when the guy turns around he
reaches in his jacket and boom the cop
shoots him the guy falls down he kind of
rolls into a curb the cop comes over as
soon as the cop comes over you very
quickly realize what's going on and that
is that the guy had headphones on
underneath his hoodie and he couldn't
hear the cop yelling at him and then as
the cop searches him he pulls out of his
pocket his iPhone and so he was just
listening to music
reaching his pocket to turn it or turn
it off and he got shot horrible
situation so how do you inoculate
yourself to that you've got to put
yourself into training situations where
you do have the instinct to take cover
well you do have the instinct to see
what people's hands are we do have the
instinct to realize that you put
yourself in a better situation where if
the guy does pull out a gun you have
time to react to it and you can react to
it from a safer distance you know as a
so there's a lot of things I would love
to start to and I don't know how you
know I I don't know how I'm I don't know
how to go about this but I would love to
start working with police departments in
some manner to get some training set up
like the training we had in the SEAL
Teams which was the training that I set
up in the SEAL Teams was psychotic how
stressful we would make it so that these
guys
were overwhelmed they were as explosions
machine-gun fire paintballs hitting them
a smoke everywhere screaming civilians
screaming wounded actors we'd hire
actors that were amputees they'd have
blood spurting all this it was
incredibly realistic and that way when
guys got into combat like one the first
time I ever got shot I was like okay
here's what's going on so I hope at some
point I can I can help the military with
that now in addition to that as you're
trying to knock yourself you're to this
violence and get used to this
watch those YouTube videos watch those
YouTube videos of street fights of
stupid encounters with with bars with
drunk people and bouncers with the shoot
or don't shoot scenarios with cops
military situations where they have
helmet cams on and you can see things
happening and what you want to do is you
want to watch those videos and you want
to pay attention to the people to the
humans and watch the reactions and watch
their movements and watch their body
language and watch their expressions on
their faces and see and judge and
predict and go to another video and hit
pause and say this is what I see right
here this is what I think is about to
happen and educate yourself on human
nature yeah because human nature is what
you're going to be dealing with and
violence is a part of human nature and
sometimes things go violent and
sometimes they don't so how do you
predict that and if you're unsure which
you will be how do you protect yourself
first and give yourself the maximum
amount of time to make a judgment call
so you don't have to rush on top of that
it's awesome that you're doing jiu-jitsu
do boxing do MoIT I do wrestling so you
get used to getting hit so you start to
see what a person's face looks like when
they're about to hit you so you start to
see what changes in there there's their
posture makes when they're about to
throw a punch
those are all things that will help you
jiu-jitsu is obviously great for the
grinding physical grappling situation
but a lot of times hopefully as a cop
most the time you're not in that
situation you're standing at a little
bit of a distance and or you're you know
you've got a little bit more time to
judge so fight as much as you can watch
those law enforcement of military videos
again see the reaction see the noise see
the fear see the panic look at people's
eyes judge them predict what they're
going to do press pause and figure out
if you were right or wrong watch
horrible violence happen so that you can
understand it better so that you can
handle it when the time arises yeah oh
and um and just kind of to add on some
of the stuff you're saying I would even
say compete if you can because a lot of
times in training you can especially if
you're training every day or pretty
often you can get into the mindset that
I can just train casual today and if a
guy taps me out which everyone says it
doesn't matter that much you know so
when you compete that's that's one of
the significant things that I got bored
that I realized when I was competing
it's your your your senses are
heightened because everything matters if
you get taken down it matters if you go
for a submission and you don't get it it
matters in in competition so you have
that that mindset more so and you'll get
used to that mindset and to your point I
tell this guys at jujitsu when you're
training for competition no matter what
we do just about no matter 98% of the
time I can't get two guys in training to
go as hard against each other as they're
going to in competition as someone when
someone gets a grip of your gear in
competition yeah it is ten times
stronger than it is when you're training
because if you rip if I get to grab your
geek collar and you go through some
effort to rip it away and we're training
I'm gonna let it go right because I
don't care yeah if it happens in
competition and I only have seven
minutes to work and get you submitted am
i hanging on to that thing
hang on to it harm ya and I'm not gonna
let go and so you end up with a much
much much more intense
seven minutes in a competition or three
minutes in a boxing sparring match or in
a more tie the intensity you cannot
simulate the intensity income in
training that you're going to get in
competition and take that one step
further when you get into a
life-and-death struggle you're going to
have the same level of jump as you the
intensity that's going to be there so
that's a good point as well
yeah and that kind of goes from my eyes
well I'm not even that certainly saying
compete in Muay Thai but we ties a good
one because right you get cracked in
your body and your legs and you get to
feel some pain
and if you're not used to that okay
before I even started Muay Thai I went
in remember Terry and so could you
he was like hey you know we we've
trained jiu-jitsu together soon as I can
I'm training MMA today come let's spar
with me my other partner doing and I was
like hey I don't have any striking
3-cycle I don't care you know Jiu Jitsu
so destroyers means occur
yeah so Brad he punched me in the face
really hard and that was you know and I
was like man just how you're talking
about this crash grenades before it was
kind of like that just the fact that I
got my to knock me out it didn't dazed
me in that way it was just the fact that
dang I wasn't used to this I didn't know
he was just gonna start punching me in
my face you know I thought we were just
gonna warm up so that's actually the
main thing that made me go into my type
specifically so so who's to get cracked
yeah cuz I was like bad I'm not even I
thought I was pretty good at Jiu Jitsu
so I figured you know like I was solid
you know but breaths so what if I get
into something you know outside of the
gym I got cracks me in my face and I'm
not usually yeah you know so then so I
the what the myth I did help is when you
get hit in the face it's like Jiu Jitsu
someone grinding on you and they're
breathing all in your nose or they're
sweating all in your eye or whatever
that doesn't bother you at all you
barely notice your knees or it doesn't
matter right so the same thing with my
tie when you get punched in the nose and
it's bleeding and you see your own blood
or whatever but if you're not you still
you that'll mess you
yeah and if you notice back in the day
like their old UFC's or whatever guys
will get cracked in the face like three
four times hard and no tap holy cow you
know because they're just not used to it
nowadays guys were just but they won't
they won't done yeah the referee got a
start on is they're used to it rarely
does anyone tap in the UFC from strikes
yeah everywhere unless they're like
injured even though you won't primary
McDonald did no yeah so anyway so the
point is so a Muay Thai situation in
specific because that's where you feel
the most pain like more than boxing like
even even I mean you'll take brain
injury for sure but it's not actual pain
wait I get kicked in the leg they teach
you to hide the pain and to not let it
affect you and go in the end and the
ribs like body like means to the ribs
this is super painful when you get used
to that I think that would help yeah
it's like if you're in a situation sweet
some cracks you hard about this you know
what's interesting about that though is
that there are some people that can can
easily or more easily take the pain of
more time or boxing like it's okay with
them then then they then they can take
the grind of jujitsu and some people can
take the grind of jujitsu all day long
but they can never take the striking
pain so it's there's just some genetic
or mental situations but to your point
you need to be comfortable with both
those situations yeah and at the very
least just familiar with it Oh like I
said that's first punch that I took in
my face and granted it was I wasn't
ready for him to just wail I mean I
definitely won football - yeah I mean so
you've been hit you've been knocked out
before on the field right so it's it's
kind of it if I were to try to remember
it was a combination of sure that
physical impact but just the fact that
this guy just punched me in my face
right now so it's almost a thing to just
punch me in my face right now but we're
gonna yeah like that but yeah after a
while it doesn't man the hardest I ever
got punched in the face was from Greg
right in the like right between my eyes
and it was like happenstance he threw a
real solid one
as I went to kind of shoot who's kind of
coming up off his knees kind of and I
went to shoot like I got I got from off
my back and then forward and shot
forward and he did went boom and the the
the force of me shooting forward and
went boom and I felt it in my neck is
really bad but it was in a hard part
yeah lucky the legend Kayode but yeah
fully that was a KO punch she just
happened to be in that really hard part
um but I been through that before I
trained Muay Thai before and it didn't
it didn't even slow me down I remember
thinking that was probably the hardest
punch I ever took and it was with an MMA
glove it wasn't the big boxing glove
well yeah back in the old days we used
to just spark all full-on with MMA
gloves on a regular basis yes stupid
yeah and but don't do that folks yeah
yeah don't do that that's a whole day
but what I'm saying is that that you
were used to it good again I was used to
it it didn't slow me down if that was
like a situation where I took that kind
of hard hit in a you know or a cop would
take that kind of hard hit and they're
used to that in training or whatever
that's not gonna slow him down that's
not gonna stun him unless it's
physically stuns us like get some other
jobs yeah and that's you know even if
you're trained that that's not that's
gonna that's gonna join in fact if you
train too much and you get yourself hit
too often you'll actually decrease your
ability to withstand punishments yeah
careful about that yes you want to Train
enough that you're used to it you want
to know that you can take it but then
you don't want to over train at all yeah
you never get better at taking well
nobody phrase that you get better at
taking punches for a short period of
time and then it goes starts to go
backwards yeah you know unfortunately
that's just the way the body's built you
can see as some of the older UFC
fighters get older you know there's no
doubt they don't have the chin that they
once had and that's when they usually
you know decide to hang it up if they
you know if they get the right counsel
from people but nowadays people are
sparring a lot less and they're trying
to not take all that punishment because
everyone realizes that you have a you
have a limited number of hits you can
take to the
to the head and then it starts to go
backwards and it's just you know a lot
of this information is coming from the
soldiers overseas the Marines overseas
that have taken concussions and Eydie
strikes and they're realizing that that
is a permanent you know downgrade of
their systems and they they you know so
they so they that's where a lot of this
information came from about football
this concussion stuff with football a
lot of that is coming from the IEDs that
our soldiers and Marines have taken
overseas and they've realized that this
traumatic trauma traumatic brain injury
is problematic and so we need to we need
to watch out for it so yeah specially if
you're being a company you got to be
alert
yeah yeah but that's why I and that's
why I like the Muay Thai that's why I
personally I did yeah because it was a
lot of like clinching knees in those if
you were if if you've never done it you
would think that being punched in the
nose square in the nose real hard would
be probably one of the more painful
things but it wasn't compared to the
ribs and the legs man so if you're kind
of used to just taking impacts in pain
yeah you just you just and not to
mention the physical part but just
mentally like when that one that comes
about you can just just keep on keeping
on now yeah because you used to it
regularly familiar yeah inoculate
inoculate yourself not kill eesh